[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
ouais
et
[Musique]
jules far away
aux mondiaux l'eau sous l'eau plutôt que
tu vas faire tu te laisse pas faire
[Musique]
la compétition
lyall procès s'il ya départ est en droit
là il y en a une seconde
alain brière la paix
alors ça fait moins mal
bah non plus
qui croire
peut-être elle va mourir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
voilà
il ya par endroits
le noir c'est un
pas faux
[Musique]
j'essaie de faire les blacks parce que
tu es à la caméra
dans cet enjeu
je vais faire une vidéo
de 37 secondes
continuez
ça sera que ça
ouais j'ai
je te quitte
[Musique]
j'en compte elles sont
dérouler
[Musique]
du
ouf
[Musique]
et m
ils ont eu trois enfants adultes
[Musique]
rés
aussi
passionnante cette vidéo juste novo
non
le sait
[Musique]
s'emmerder à faire des
en couple
[Musique]
jusque là il ya des votes
c
3 millions
non j'ai pas la 4 4
facilement
pendant 3 minutes 30 il parle encore
l'inventeur de jeu
m
c'est l'euro qui a tâté la vitre
c'est l'osm au capitalisme
c'est pas moi
la région de la primature
kg hab le voit le temps doux
je vais plus jamais passer devant sion
le film un peu
ou bakambu
super entendu
et
mon argent
l'avion
le temple de toledo de total
s'amuser en mesure à temps plein
[Musique]
en attendant leur temps
cette vidéo est amusante
précieusement pour
c'est quoi
[Musique]
rien
l'itu
à ses côtés à temps c'est plus
intéressant tenant beaucoup caudan
oui le musée de la poste
[Musique]
à bâle ou à se faire mais tu penses
on fait alors d'autres postes plongé de
la fosse on peut envoyer des lettres
depuis le musée père costes
salut
on en a fonction de vacances que nous
aimons tant les enfants oui papa c'est
quand qu'on arrive à faire pipi c'est
[Musique]
déjà fait mais au penseur toi seigneur
on le trouve également tu connais
l'autre s'engageant notamment à paris
ouais qu'est ce que tu fais non mais pas
à plat un mois il veut te filmer toi
france bouge il dit non on filme day
[Musique]
je pratique ma foi c'est parce que cette
fois on se voit
vous battez tous étaient pris dans le
feu au lac de pointer au delà vous
quittez plus enfin plus clair vous ne
voyez pas c'est ce que j'aime faire du
coup
[Musique]
du coup quand des prix
attendu fin avril au plus tard oui on
est à 7 minutes 30 je vais la loi des
d'un coup ce sera fait sur youtube
[Musique]
laquelle adhèrent
soyez déposé
enfin je valais coupé dans la rue les
conneries
cyclisme en france
olé
une expérience
moi
pour ce faire
ck couleur musique l'ordre d'accord moi
je fais cette vidéo c'est ok mais ça
devient dérangeant